[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and my
last video was about the new macbook the
super thin super light new laptop from
apple and it got a lot of chatter for a
bunch of reasons but mainly the fact
that it only has
one port it's rocking a single usbc port
on the side which got people talking
like is this important should i take
note of this now this usbc thing is it a
big deal what is apple trying to say
about usbc so this is everything you
need to know about usb type-c so there's
a bunch of different new ports out there
that you might have seen hdmi 2.0
displayport
thunderbolt and lightning just to name a
few and they're all pioneered by
different manufacturers because they all
have different purposes they're all
built to do different things thunderbolt
for example designed by intel and made
specifically to attach peripherals to a
computer lightning is designed by apple
it's made specifically to charge and
connect low power accessories like
iphones and ipads then seemingly out of
nowhere we get this usbc it seems like
just another new port but the key to
usbc
is the u
it's universal usb can be used by anyone
anywhere it's not proprietary and that's
why pretty much every android phone you
see out there has a usb port of some
kind so usbc is usb 3.1 so we've
probably all seen a computer with usb
2.0 ports those are everywhere and over
the past couple of years we've seen more
and more of these usb 3.0 ports those
are the super speed ones that usually
have blue on the inside so now we're
looking at usb 3.1 and the smaller type
c connector the port so that's why this
is called usb type c usb 2.0 and 3.0
come in the form of full size usb but
also micro usb and mini usb and a bunch
of other versions usb 3.1 is just the
one tiny port so you have it in laptops
but you can also have it in computers
and tablets and smartphones and monitors
pretty much everything can use this tiny
port so how is it better than the
previous version how is usb 3.1 type c
better than usb 2.0 or 3.0 number one
it's smaller and thinner so it can fit
in the thinnest of the thin devices
along with all the thick normal sized
ones number two it's super versatile it
can carry up to a hundred watts of power
so you can charge full size electronics
and it can carry data at up to 10
gigabits per second which is a super
high data transfer rate you can run a 4k
monitor off of this you can run a super
fast ssd rate into something off of this
it's very fast and very powerful and
number three it's backwards compatible
with usb 3.0 and 2.0
and it's reversible so you can plug it
in the right way the first time
every single time so usbc in its
reversible glory is great and everything
but where are we going to start to see
this be used is it going to be popular
in the future
yes it's going to be everywhere the new
macbook might be one of the first to use
usbc but it will definitely not be the
only one and i guess this is apple being
super aggressive and very apple about it
about making a statement that usb-c is
the future by making it the only port in
their new machine but it's certainly
going to be a lot more plentiful in the
second generation in fact i can pretty
much guarantee the second generation of
this thin and light new macbook will
have more than one usb port quote me
this is the chromebook pixel it came out
recently and would you look at that it
has two usbc ports one on either side
which is actually really convenient
because you can choose to plug in to
power on the left side or the right side
just based on where you are on your desk
it's nice now these early machines with
just one or two usb-c ports on them are
not exactly meant to be powerhouses if
you've noticed a theme it's a chromebook
and a tiny sort of a netbook style so
they're not meant to connect a lot of
peripherals to them and if you do want
to you'll need adapters and trust me
they're willing to sell you lots and
lots of adapters for now but in the
future machines that are meant to be
more powerful will have many more usb-c
ports expect to see this port in not
only a bunch of laptops but a bunch of
tablets and a bunch of future
smartphones and basically anywhere you
see a usb port now whether it's full
size or micro usb or mini usb
expect that to turn into a usb-c port
pretty soon so we'll get this in
products from not just apple and google
but samsung and motorola and asus and
there's actually already a nokia n1
tablet with just a usb type-c port
already also check out this clip from a
google video and you can say what you
want about what the next nexus looks
like already but i think this is a
pretty good indication that that too
will have a usbc port
we at google are very committed to the
usb type c spec
expect to see this in a lot of
chromebooks and android phones in the
near future
so there you go i think it's safe to say
that computers of the future will have
plenty of usbc ports laptops of the
future will just be lined with a bunch
of usbc
and that's the vision i guess the dream
is to just have one charger that you can
charge any of your electronics with
would be nice so usbc is on its way in
get ready for it buy your adapters now
while they're cheap or not from apple
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
guys in the next one
peace